digamos que queremos saber en dónde se
encuentra el centro de masa que está
entre esta masa de 2 kilogramos y esta
masa de 6 kilogramos estas masas están
separadas 10 centímetros por lo que se
encontrará entre ellas y nosotros
sabemos que el centro de masa se va a
encontrar más cercano a la masa más
grande pero queremos saber exactamente
dónde se va a encontrar pues necesitamos
una fórmula para calcularlo y la fórmula
para el centro de masa luce así dice que
la ubicación del centro de masa que es
esta x c m es la posición del centro de
masa y esto va a ser igual a todas las
masas que tengamos involucradas en
nuestro problema entre las cuales
queremos encontrar el centro de masa y a
cada masa la vamos a multiplicar por su
posición sumamos todas estas m por equis
y todo esto lo vamos a dividir entre la
suma de todas las masas del sistema y lo
que nos va a dar esto como resultado es
la ubicación del centro
así que vamos a usar esto para resolver
nuestro problema de ejemplo así que
tenemos que la posición del centro de
masa va a ser igual a m 1 y digamos que
m 1 podríamos elegir cualquier masa como
m 1 pero resulta que ya color esta masa
de 2 kilogramos con el color rojo así
que voy a usarla como masa 1 así que
tomo mi masa de 2 kilogramos y la
multiplicó por su posición x 1 y en este
punto ustedes probablemente estén
confundidos y digan bueno yo aquí no veo
ninguna coordenada no sé cuál posición
tenga la masa 1 en este tipo de casos
nosotros decidimos a partir de donde
medimos estas posiciones y de donde sea
que queramos medir las posiciones
tenemos que ser consistentes y hacer
todas nuestras mediciones a partir de
ese mismo punto de origen a partir de
ese mismo punto también mediremos la
posición del centro de masa en otras
palabras nosotros decidimos en donde va
a estar x igual a 0
comodidad digamos que x0 esté aquí en mi
masa 1 aquí está mi x0 en esta recta
numérica y digamos que a la derecha voy
a tener cantidades positivas así que si
esto es x
0 a medio camino tendré x igual a 5 y
hasta este otro punto tendré x igual a
10 tenemos la libertad de elegir en
donde ponemos nuestra medición lo que es
genial porque si yo digo que esto es x
igual a cero la posición de la masa 1 es
de 0 por lo que este término se vuelve 0
a esto le tenemos que agregar m2 que es
6 kilogramos
multiplicado por la posición de la masa
2 y nuevamente podríamos elegir
cualquier posición que queramos pero hay
que ser consistentes si ya establecimos
que este punto de aquí es x igual a cero
a partir de aquí tenemos que medir todas
las distancias en mi sistema así que a
partir de aquí voy a medir la distancia
de mi masa 2 que es entonces de 10
centímetros sólo tengo dos masas
involucradas por lo que aquí termino y
ahora voy a dividir todo esto entre la
suma de todas las masas por lo que tengo
mi masa uno de dos kilogramos más mi
masa 2 que es de 6 kilogramos y esto es
igual a 2 por 0 0 6 por 10 60 kilogramos
por centímetros entre dos más 6 88
kilogramos lo que nos da 7.5 centímetros
por lo que va a estar a 7.5 centímetros
del punto que definimos como
de las distancias x0 y nuestro punto de
centro de masa estaría por acá
esta es la ubicación del centro de masa
en otras palabras si conectamos estas
dos masas con una barra y pusiéramos un
pivote aquí estarían en equilibrio en
este punto de aquí y para mostrarles que
podemos elegir cualquier punto como x
igual a 0 y si eligiéramos otro punto
como x igual a 0 tendríamos un resultado
diferente pues si digamos que ahora
hacemos esto en lugar de decir que aquí
está x igual a cero ahora decimos que
nuestra x igual a cero se encuentra de
este otro lado ahora nuestra x igual a
cero se encuentra en la posición de
nuestra masa de seis kilogramos que
obtendremos entonces pues nuestra
ubicación del centro de masa va a ser
igual tenemos dos kilogramos de nuestra
masa 1 pero ahora la ubicación de la
masa uno se encuentra medida a partir de
x0 si esto es x0 y hacia la derecha
consideramos cantidades positivas a la
izquierda van a estar las
es negativas por lo que esta posición
estará en menos 10 centímetros ya que se
encuentra a la izquierda de x igual a
cero así que aquí tenemos menos 10
centímetros más 6 kilogramos por la
posición de la masa 2 que está en x
igual a cero por lo que esto lo
multiplicamos por cero y esto lo
dividimos entre la suma de ambas masas 2
kilogramos más 6 kilogramos y ahora
vamos a tener 2 x menos 10 va a ser
igual a menos 20 más 6 por 0 va a ser
cero así que aquí tenemos menos 20
kilogramos centímetro dividido entre 8
kilogramos esto nos da menos 2.5
centímetros y como ven el resultado es
diferente y quizá les preocupe que
estemos teniendo dos resultados
diferentes pero la ubicación no va a
cambiar aunque cambiemos la posición
desde donde estamos midiendo las
distancias nuestro centro de masa sigue
en la misma posición ya que
ahora estos menos 2.5 centímetros los
estoy midiendo a partir de esta x igual
a 0 y en donde quedan estos 2.5
centímetros hacia la izquierda a partir
de aquí pues quedan acá exactamente en
el mismo punto ya que a partir de aquí
son 7.5 centímetros pero a partir de acá
son 2.5 centímetros hacia la izquierda y
todo esto nos da 10 centímetros que es
la distancia entre estas dos masas por
lo que encontramos exactamente la misma
posición para el centro de masa y tiene
que ser así ya que no puede cambiar su
posición si cambiamos el punto de
referencia desde donde pedimos nuestras
distancias no importa si llamo a este
punto cero o a este punto cero pero hay
que tener cuidado y ser consistentes con
nuestra elección si nosotros decidimos
que esta es nuestra posición de origen
nos va a servir pero hay que ser
consistentes y medir todas nuestras
distancias a partir de este punto que ya
elegimos
de otra forma no podremos interpretar lo
que significa este número
en resumen pueden usar la fórmula del
centro de masa para encontrar la
ubicación exacta del centro de masa que
está en un sistema de objetos sumamos
todas las masas multiplicadas por su
posición y el resultado lo dividimos
entre la masa total del sistema
la posición puede medirse a partir de
cualquier punto que nosotros indiquemos
que sea x igual a 0 y el número que
obtenemos a partir de este cálculo será
la distancia a partir de x igual a 0
hasta el centro de masa del sistema